PROFESSOR: Hi, guys.
My name is Nikola,
and in this video,
we're going to
work out an example
of an orthogonal
projection matrix.
Specifically, we are gonna
compute the projection matrix
onto the plane given by the
equation x plus y minus z
equals 0.
So before we start,
let me just recall
what a projection matrix is.
So you've seen this sketch
here a million times already.
A projection matrix takes any
vector in three-space-- well,
just in this case, we are
dealing with a three-space--
and projects it
down onto the plane,
a two-dimensional
subspace of R^3.
So I'll give you a few
moments to consider
the problem for yourselves.
And then you'll
see my take on it.
Hi again.
So in lecture, Professor Strang
derived, in meticulous detail,
the formula for the
projection matrix.
So it was given by the
following slightly complicated
expression.
It's A times A
transpose A inverse A
transpose where A
is a matrix that
somehow encodes the subspace
we're projecting on.
In particular, A has, as
its columns, a_1, a_2,
I'm going to denote them--
a basis for the plane we're
projecting on.
So essentially,
what we need to do
is find two such vectors
that span the plane and start
computing with a matrix.
This is fairly straightforward.
One choice that works,
for example, is [1, -1, 0]
for the first column, and [1, 0,
1] for the second column.
And let me write out the
matrix A. So in the formula,
the slightly more
complicated combination
is A transpose A inverse, so let
me compute that first for you.
So A transpose A
is a 2 by 2 matrix.
And it's not so hard to figure
out that it's 2 and 1; 1, 2.
Now we shall invert it
using the familiar formula.
1 over the determinant.
2 times 2 minus 1 is 3.
And so we switch the
diagonal entries,
and we flip the signs of
the off-diagonal ones.
Right.
And therefore, projection
matrix is given by the following
product of matrices:
...1/3, [2, -1; -1,
2] and then transpose of A,
which is [1, -1, 0; 1, 0, 1].
I'm gonna carry out
this multiplication
in inhumanly fast fashion.
So I'm just gonna write down
the answer, which is 1/3
[2, -1, 1; -1, 2, 2; 1, 1, 1].
So what you can
do now is-- well,
you can check whether this
answer actually makes sense.
One thing you can
do is just-- well,
a projection matrix is
supposed to take the normal
to the plane down to 0.
So you can just multiply P and
the normal vector [1, 1, -1].
And if you get 0, maybe
you've done a good job.
Another curious thing that I
would like to point out here
is: so you see we had
lots of freedom choosing
the matrix A. We could have
chosen any two columns that
span the subspace,
that spans the plane.
The beautiful thing about
it is that in the end,
we'll get the same answer.
So I hope there
will be many of you
who would say, hey, there is an
easier way to do the problem.
And I'll agree
with these people.
So let's see what would
be an easier approach.
Well, let's go back
to the sketch here.
And let's make the
following observation,
that any vector is a
sum of two components.
The first component is its
projection onto the plane.
And the other component
is its projection
onto the orthogonal complement
of the plane, in this case,
onto the normal vector
through the plane.
So in the language
of linear algebra,
this is just b equals
to its projection
onto the plane plus
its projection-- I'm
gonna call it P_N-- onto
the orthogonal complement
of the plane.
I'm gonna suggestively
write here the identity
matrix so that you
can immediately
read off a matrix equality.
Associated with this
equality here, it's
the identity equals P plus P_N.
And therefore, the
projection matrix
is just the identity minus
the projection matrix
onto the normal vector.
Now, this object here, P_N, is
much easier to compute, well,
for two reasons.
First one is that projecting
onto a one-dimensional subspace
is infinitely easier
than projecting
onto a higher-dimensional
subspace.
And second, we already
have-- well, immediately we
can read off from the
equation of the plane what
the normal vector is.
So we don't have
derive these guys.
We don't have to do
what we did here.
So essentially, P_N will be
N N transpose N inverse N
transpose.
And that's equal to [1, 1, -1]--
N transpose N inverse,
this is just a number.
It's 1 over the magnitude
of the normal vector,
so that's-- then, the
magnitude squared, so that's 3.
And 1, 1, -1.
I'm gonna write the answer here.
It's 1/3, 1, 1, -1; 1,
1, -1; and -1, 1, 1.
And in order to get the
projection matrix-- yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Thank you.
And in order to get
the projection matrix,
we just subtract from the
identity this expression.
And you can confirm that it's--
we get the same answer as here.
I think we're done here.